Elon musk's dad
says he's worried the Tesla CEO might be
assassinated following a report about
his influence on government decisions
okay so let's let's take a look at this
here
and this is an Insider story yes
response Errol musk when asked if he
fears a potential assassination of his
son Elon Musk by the shadow government
stemming from a New Yorker article which
he labels a hit job as per the son
interviewed the New Yorker article
portrays Elon Musk as an unelected
official prompting Pentagon officials to
express unease over his attitude towards
Vladimir Putin and acknowledging
spacex's Starling a satellite's critical
role in Ukrainian conflict Elon musk's
personal security concerns are evident
as he shares how his son's car
faced a crazy stalker situation and his
actions such as requesting an office
bathroom and restricting journalists who
shared an account tracking his private
jet reflecting his complex relationship
with safety measures so Tom what are
your thoughts on this relationship
between Ilana and his dad and what is
that a saying about about Iran's safety
he and his dad are strained I think
everybody's read various comments about
it and you know he's terrible human
being those are pretty heavy words
between a father and son and I think
right now he's out there saying I'm
worried this guy might be assassinated
and I also think what's going on is um
we've had some very light news cycles
and so you pull this up and his dad
makes some comment like that and I think
you know
yeah do I think there's a real risk
there perhaps do I think his dad's
worried about it because he sees his son
really being a lightning rod here
absolutely I think his dad I think his
dad believes hey man you're touching
government you're touching you know very
heavy figures and you're demanding you
know this and that this uh you know I'm
a little worried that maybe somebody
might be upset enough about this to pop
him are you following the ADL story with
uh musk or no uh lightly I understand
you pull up that story with Forbes the
Anti-Defamation League oh my ad Revenue
has been manipulated because adl's been
out there pulling threads Tom let's not
forget the end of the day Pat Uh Elon
Musk spent how much money to buy X
Twitter 40 billion 40 billion dollars to
be like the Free Speech King because I
think it was 42 remember at the end of
the day Pat because of him and this
wasn't by the way obviously the FBI why
everybody was involved in embedded
inside of Twitter especially during the
election he's given us the opportunity
now on Twitter that we can see and hear
everything okay we see it we can fact
check it out we do what we just did and
we debate and everybody could have their
opinion but it's all out there the truth
though the fact that we can find out the
truth for ourselves makes him an enemy
of the elite he is giving us the
platform to do exactly what the hell we
did Pat and from from watching the
people on the ground in Maui talk about
what's really happening I'm saying to
listening to Larry Sinclair credible or
not whatever you want to say to the
January 6 Twitter files where it was the
January 6 guided tour it was an
Insurrection all the that they lied
to us about we get to see it and Pat I'm
telling you right now if there was a
list of accidental let's get this guy
Elon would be on top of that list right
now because he's giving us the
opportunity to see all the fiction about
covet to see all this and like just
let's put it on the table let us look at
it and figure it out before that would
you have ever have known all the
about Twitter or Hunter Biden or the
Latin none of that none of that time
because the White House the FBI were
going to Twitter and they were putting
agents there to say don't put the story
out do this do that do that so I 100
think that he's on that list no the
modern government does not want an open
platform so musk blames Anti-Defamation
League for X's poor ad sales threatens
lawsuit go a little lower ilama says U.S
ad revenue for X formerly known as
Twitter was down 60 in a series of
tweets Monday and blamed it on critical
statements from the anti-defamational
league going so far as to threaten a
lawsuit against the group go lower musk
said the uh advertisers have told the
company they're receiving pressure from
ADL a Jewish non-governmental
organization that seeks to fight
anti-Semitism and extremism around the
world to not advertise on X he went to
say if this continues we will have no
choice but to file a defamation suit
against ironically the anti-defamational
League this comes after a deal released
multiple reports saying
anti-semitic reports uh posts have
spiked on X since musk's purchased the
platform unblocked the number of users
who had previously been kicked off the
site for violating hate speech and
loosened the platform's consent content
moderation policy I mean you can't blame
the guy for being upset about it this is
canceling by any other word if you can't
control can't get them to be quiet you
try to cancel them and if the ADL
doesn't like what certain people are
saying whether those people are truly
extremists and truly saying things uh
you know against Jewish people which I
hate to see but there there's a hyper
reaction here and they can't control X
so they want to influence others who can
cause control through cancellation and
boycotts yeah I don't believe in any
sort of cancellation even though I'm
Jewish you know I believe in free speech
I'm a free speech
absolutist to an extent
um I actually believe you should shine a
light on the people that are saying
racist anti-semitic bigoted comments
let's see who they are let's see I want
to see a picture of their face I
actually want to know where they live
let's see where they work highlight the
hell out of these guys
let's see what's going on let's dox the
hell out of these guys so yeah I totally
understand why someone like Elon would
want to push back against the ADL a lot
of people do uh but this is literally
their job is to go after people they
feel like are defaming minorities or uh
certain types of people
um but back to the Elon thing
him and his father have had a very
strand relationship over the years
um so I actually don't know how much
communication they even have so you said
it's maybe a light Newsweek so they're
just looking for anything uh to kind of
drum up but um pure speculation and I'm
sure elon's got it covered actually the
most famous text that Elon and his
father had this was a year ago was when
he texts his dad
um just keep quiet the Press is playing
you like a fiddle
um don't say anything anymore keep quiet
so he's basically saying dad
pump the brakes guys so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign